[Music]
if you were concerned about record
inflation up around seven percent
especially this christmas season when
people are buying a lot of food and
buying a lot of presents
i've got i can't say it's good news for
you it's just that the number to worry
about is not the seven percent
it's the the nearly 10
of wholesale inflation that we have seen
it's even worse than we were told it was
going to be
this as you're looking to buy your
christmas
steak or presents for your loved one all
in this year that we were told was going
to be a return
to normalcy the main argument for joe
biden is his good old uncle joe he's
moderate he's been around forever and
we're going to return from normal after
so many crazy years under donald trump
some people predicted that things were
going to be radical including my friend
sean spicer sean spicer was the 28th
white house press secretary under donald
trump he wasn't the 28th one under
donald trump but he was the 28th white
house press secretary and he was
secretary under donald trump he has a
wonderful show spicer and co which i
love watching and i love being on by the
way as well that is on newsmax on
weekdays and he's the author of the new
book radical nation sean thank you for
coming on
hey it's a pleasure to be with you it's
always great to have you on the show as
well it's nice to to trade places though
and answer your questions i feel so
powerful i really i really love this but
as a citizen i don't feel very powerful
right now because everything i don't
think i'm being hyperbolic every single
thing has gotten worse under joe biden
this is reflected in his poll numbers
he's underwater on every issue including
on kovid which was the one issue that he
was kind of above water on for a little
bit so
how did the biden administration turn
out so radically differently than what
we were told it was going to be
so two things first you know to your
point i i was i think it was last sunday
night my wife and i took the kids we're
out at the grocery store at the top of
our street just getting some stuff you
know picking up stuff we'd already done
grocery shopping for the for the rest of
the week and i'm sort of a lemon addict
i have lemons in the morning i just it's
become the new health thing i guess so i
i keep getting told that you put lemon
and everything and apparently that'll
make me
skinny and healthy so
anyway i know to buy lemons and i look
at my wife it was 99 cents a lemon and
now granted they were supposed to be the
lard lemons and i'm like holy smokes
when did lemons become 99 cents but that
just tells you and then she was looking
at something else that she had gotten on
thanksgiving we were in the produce area
and she said you know when i was here
for thanksgiving this was like four
dollars and 80 cents it's now 7.20 i
mean it to your point
everything's becoming more expensive but
to your question michael the reason i
called it radical nation
wasn't because sean spicer thought joe
biden was going to be radical or the
daily wire was saying that joe biden
it's because
during the presidential campaign
joe biden pledged to be the most
progressive president ever he said it no
one took him seriously and i and mostly
people on the right and that you had all
these establishment right-wingers coming
out and saying i've known joe biden
who's in the senate he's a pragmatist
he's a moderate he's an institutionalist
but biden understood something that i
don't think we all appreciated which he
understood legacy and that if you're
only going to get four years which let's
be honest that's what's going to happen
that you can either try to accomplish a
great deal or you can do a great deal
that cements your legacy one of the
first things i write about in the book
is this meeting he had in the cabinet
room with all these liberal historians
talking about how to outdo fdr
and so you've seen him
not through action in policy although
that's part of it but through
appointment kamala harris the first
woman of color pete butterjudge the
first lgbtq
person to lead a department not in the
cabinet which was grinnell but to lead a
department and all of these things first
transgender force star because all of
these things allow him to say i was more
progressive i was more liberal i was
more radical
than anybody else and we missed it and i
think that we've got to make sure that
we understand his goal
so that we can continue to protect the
country this is a great point because i
the reason that i never believed the
whole biden's a moderate he's going to
be a return to normal thing is that i
think joe biden's political ideology
involves licking his index finger when
he gets up in the morning he puts it in
the air figures out whichever way the
wind is blowing that's going to be joe
biden's view that day i the man i i
don't say it to be mean but he
he is as empty a suit as i have ever
seen in american politics but but what
you're suggesting is a little more than
that which is
it's it's wonderful to become president
but if you become one of those
presidents
that are just totally forgotten
william henry harrison i don't know
there are not a lot of post offices to
william henry harrison that's that's
almost worse than never being president
at all so you've got you've got to
accomplish something and he is doing a
lot of things they just appear to be
backfiring
well but if you understand if you're 78
years old and you you know enough first
of all it's funny that you mention the
policy stuff there's a whole chapter in
the book that i love about his position
on being pro-life i mean he started off
as a big defender of
of life and talking about life begins at
conception and roe was wrongly decided
and now suddenly he doesn't remember all
those quotes he gave to catholic
newspapers in delaware when he was a
senator but
look
he he understands i'm 78 years old i'd
be 82 when i ran i'm way too old to
begin with now
and so if i do a bunch of stuff and
again i think the policy is part of it
packing the court making dc a state
expanding government allowing illegals
to vote all of that is part of it but
the one thing that you can't take away
from if nothing else gets passed and i
think some of it will
he can at least say i appointed all
these people and he is the north star
for progressive leftists forever saying
well biden appointed the first woman of
color to vp what will you do he
appointed the first transgender four
star what will you do and so now
biden has become the left wing bar just
as fdr has been for the last several
decades how do you outdo fdr how do you
grow the government well he has now sort
of realized i need to outdo fdr but in
my own way in a way that i don't have to
rely on policy
that's very perceptive because it
reminds me and i had forgotten this that
joe biden actually jumped barack obama
on the issue of redefining marriage
before obama was
we forget now but every democrat was
vehemently opposed to redefining
marriage and then in 2011 uh
right around 2011 before the 2012
campaign biden came out and said i'm i'm
for gay marriage and and then obama
finally came out with it as well so
there is this idea if i can't actually
accomplish anything i'm at least going
to be the new bar i'm going to be the
furthest out there on this issue of
pro-life i'd love to get your opinion
because you've been around dc a long
time you're a fellow mackerel snapping
papist such as myself uh you're very
pro-life
joe biden and the entire democrats have
given up any even pretense of being
pro-life at this point
on the court though we just heard the
oral arguments in the dobbs feed jackson
women's health this could overrule roe
versus wade
if you were a gamblin man sean what do
you think happens in this case
so my personal view is i think that what
they're going to do is thread the needle
you saw kavanaugh give commitments to
susan collins of maine during his
confirmation process
and so i think what they want to do is
stay consistent to their commitments and
to the precedent that the court has said
but what they're going to say is
that this new law is consistent it's
saying that that the states have the
right to do something up to the point of
viability or science texas or technology
which is what it is now so therefore
they're just going to allow the bar to
move down to say 15 weeks is the new bar
but i think that they're not going to
overturn roe they're just going to move
the bar and say that what texas i mean
what mississippi did and then
subsequently we'll talk about texas but
what mississippi did is consistent
with row because all it's doing is
moving the bar if you will with with
technology and science it's not taking
the role of of the federal government
it's not it's not unprotecting it i just
now maybe
maybe somehow you get a majority vote
and i'm wrong on this i'm not i'm not a
lawyer i'm not a scotus watcher but i
think that the commitments those guys
made in their confirmation process
they've got to find a way to thread that
needle so that's what i believe will
happen well you can certainly see chief
justice roberts
trying doing everything he can in that
in the oral arguments to try to figure
out some way well but hold on is it it's
15 weeks is not viability but is there
please please lawyers give me some way
to uphold the law while not overruling
row
yeah and i think that that's he's but
look he would give us
you know the sixth vote i think we've
got five um so the ques i think there's
no question but but one of the things
that we on the right need to do and
lindsey keith you mentioned my show at
six o'clock in new york so we've had
these conversations off and on is i
think we need to get ahead of the
decision because the left is going to
try to define whatever it is as an
overturning of roe v wade in the end of
abortion even if roe was overturned
that's not the end of abortion i mean
gavin newsom just declared california a
sanctuary state right where people can
come and have abortions at will god
willing i mean
it's disgusting
right yeah yeah but but but the point is
is that all roe did was codified at the
federal level undoing roe would just say
there's nothing that it doesn't have
anything to do with abortion has to do
with who has the ability to regulate it
and in this case it would be thrown back
to the states which it should be
right this this is an important point
because for all the fear-mongering from
the left uh overrule of roe vs wade
would change abortion laws in a number
of states but then you would have say
california or new york saying we're
going to be sanctuaries which would then
raise the prospect of interstate
commerce and maybe there would be
another federal case about about
pro-life there so
one of the arguments i've heard from
cynical republicans who maybe they're
pro-life maybe they're not pro-life but
they say you know regardless of what
happens with roe the only bad thing is
it's going to hurt us in the midterms
because if they do overrule roe sure
it'll save millions of babies but you
know we might we might not win back as
many house seats as we want do you know
is is this a legitimate fear do you
think that an overruling of roe could
could harm us in 2022 or we do we have
so much momentum behind us that the
house is ours
well first no secondly if you want to
run for office and can't stand for your
convictions and get out of the game
um if you can't sit there and say i am a
proud supporter of life i will do what i
can to defend it and message it well
then get out of the business you're bad
i don't want people who can't defend it
um i think frankly there's too many
people that defend it that do a bad job
do it i'd rather have people who can get
up there and explain it well and talk
about i i listened to governor tate
reeves of mississippi a few weeks ago he
did a phenomenal job yeah um there are
ways and and i think the work that susan
b anthony list um has been doing with
these ads explaining from doctors how
technology has evolved so that what we
saw in um in a
sonogram back in 1973 isn't close to
what we can see now the viability of
life has clearly
improved vastly
weeks
in terms of
viability
and so i think we should be talking
about that we should be promoting
adoption there's a lot of things that
the folks on the right should be doing
ahead of that decision because in some
way shape or form
the decision will somehow create a new
debate um even if it didn't get over i
mean no matter what tinkering it does
and so we should start now we know the
decision is likely to come down in june
so let's get ahead of it but if you're
going to run for office as a republican
and you can't stand up and say
i support life and i'm willing to do
whatever it takes and even if it means
losing my seat then i don't want you
representing the republican party well
on
here here totally agree on this issue of
the elections i guess this does kind of
bring us back to the book radical nation
which is
regardless of the issue of abortion and
a lot of polls show that people actually
are not all that motivated by support of
abortion right and i'm glad you brought
that up that's the other thing there's
this false premise i'm thank you for
mentioning this because there's this
sense that somehow as an issue it's a
loser i don't believe that it's also so
when you look at polls i spent most of
my life in the campaign world and
there's an issue there's a there's a big
decision between whether it whether you
care about the issue and whether you
will vote on the issue in other words if
you're a single issue voter then yes
that matters but if you abortion is one
of ten issues like in other words
is abortion a huge issue for me yes do i
support candidates who are pro-life yes
but at the end of a day if it's a choice
between a democrat and a republican i'll
still take the republican so in other
words it's not where republicans miss
this sometimes is they think somehow if
i don't agree with the far left in the
media i'm going to lose and that's not
how it works right that's it's a very
important distinction and i think the
left knows it you know they're they're
reading these polls pretty pretty
closely now on the subject of the polls
joe biden as we mentioned earlier is is
underwater his approval rating somewhere
around 38 percent kamala harris
incredibly is worse her approval rating
is somewhere around 27
lower than dick cheney after after the
iraq war's worst days and after shooting
a man in the face so that's not good for
her
you've got bootage edges very low he's
also around 37 38
rest of the cabinet really really low so
okay maybe joe biden will be written
about in some history books as as the
new bar of leftism maybe he'll even get
some post offices named after him but
but what is the white house thinking
right now pushing policies that are so
deeply unpopular that that all of their
numbers are in the gutter and it might
kill them at the ballot box so it's
funny i have a chapter in the book
chapter five kamala harris president in
waiting and i think this goes back to
the point i made um
they chose her not because of her
experience if you think about it you go
back uh gore to clinton jamie to bush
biden to obama right these are all vice
presidents that were able to augment
their president experience in government
in politics kamala harris had four years
in the senate she was chosen because the
color of her skin and her gender that's
it so she can't excel because she was
she was pushed out by her own party in
the primary process before iowa i mean
you're basically picking the team the
guy that gets cut in the first round
you're like yeah i want him to be the
team captain it doesn't i mean and then
you wonder why you're like hey the guy
can't hit no kidding
you know it's it's you picked the worst
person yeah and they wonder why their
approval ratings at 28 i don't think it
takes a course in political science to
figure it out the bottom line is you
pick the loser
and um and so i'm not shocked by this i
don't know why anybody is shocked by
this but the reality is is that um they
picked somebody
who wasn't qualified to do it and then
the the policy piece michael comes back
to what we're talking about it's not
about popularity
it's not about getting it done it's
about how do i cement this legacy so if
i pass and remember here's the dirty
secret that everybody needs to remember
they're going to lose the house nancy
pelosi has already announced she's not
running for reelection so whether you
lose the house by 5 or 20 who cares they
realize is that i want to pass these
progressive things trillions of dollars
in spending that will addict people to
government for future generations i want
to get more people to vote that are not
in this country legally because it will
affect future generations of democratic
power i can do all those things and who
cares katie by the door i have 12 months
to do them i will become the most
heralded left-wing politician so win-win
this isn't about popularity and trying
to to win a re-election this is about
becoming the most progressive president
ever and and i guess you see that even
with the selection of kamala harris
because as you say she was the first one
out she was deeply unlikable
but
now joe biden gets credit he picked the
first woman vice president and she's a
woman of color he had said during the
campaign i will pick a black woman to be
vice president so he had three choices
in terms of prominent black women on his
side in politics he had kamala harris uh
carol bass karen karen baz rather who is
an actual communist like actually has
been a member of communist organizations
and susan rice who was the fall man for
benghazi
so so there was the one yeah the one
choice and she happened to be extremely
unlikable in it and it is going to to
harm them but i i suppose
you're right it's the it's not just
about the 2022 election or even the 2024
election
it's about the long game it's like it's
about the legacy right it's this is
about how will i be remembered and if if
we go down in history talking about
all of this spending and what it did to
get people because it's not just the
spending it's a bailout to trial or is
it a bailout to the media remember this
isn't build back better billions of
dollars to trial lawyers billions to the
media
billions to you know all of these other
left-wing climate change stuff so he
will be the that guy that i talked about
the north star that well hey biden did
it biden got us this why can't you do it
now
assuming that kamala remains extremely
unpopular and assuming that joe biden
doesn't know what his name is half the
time
what do you say i don't want to make you
pull out a crystal ball but i sort of
actually do want you to do that what do
you see happening for the democrats in
2024 you have a pretty good track record
calling what was going to happen under
biden so what's going to happen next
so i under the current environment i see
pete butterj as the 2024 nominee now
interestingly and i just want to make
sure people understand this because in
the book i've got a chapter going
through what i call biden inc and buddha
juice is one of the people and i talk
about the fact that he's a 38 year old
mayor of a small town in indiana south
bend 100 000 people and 66 buses so he
wasn't exactly the best choice to lead a
department that oversees our air base
seaways and highways that being said
the the establishment left sees bootage
as the future he is articulate good
looking uh he's a veteran he can really
articulate positions well and and debate
well those are all things that are true
i don't doubt any of those
they look at him as the future and
because he's
lbgtq he checks a box he's not just a
white dude right he can say that he's
you know part of the minority and so to
them
uh and and everyone understands that
kamala harris just doesn't have the
qualities that endear herself
to anybody and therefore um you know he
to them to these establishment folks in
dc
is the guy and i i think that look
here's the dirty secret all the money
that was passed in the infrastructure
bill
he gets to run around the country for
the next three years being like hey it's
me mayor pete with 4 billion dollars
going into communities and talking about
bridges and roads and helping them
rebuild their communities i mean you
couldn't ask for a better job if you
wanted a president in three years that's
extraordinarily perceptive because you
wonder when was the last transportation
secretary that we saw become president
well look at the build back better
agenda look at what that really means
and
they like they might as well start using
funds to build floats for the guy
this is going to be buda judge highway
buddha judge bridge to replace all those
racist bridges that that buddha judge
was so angry about and i think you're
right that
the man is harvard educated gay
and perfectly glib he is
the ruling class's
ideal of his he is their dream sort of
candidate and he's he like biden i
suppose probably doesn't believe a damn
thing and is willing to lick his finger
put it up in the air and figure which
way the wind is blowing which in the
past four years
or rather the past
year and for the total four years of the
administration seem to be blowing pretty
far to the left if you want to read
about it and a really spot-on assessment
and prediction of what has been going on
when a lot of people got it wrong you
got to check out radical nation by sean
spicer and sean's excellent show
spicer and company six o'clock on
newsmax sean
thank you of course for coming on
thanks michael always a pleasure
appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
you